c'est une première pour le club de
basket de trappes des paniers en profit
du téléthon
les enfants ont commencé il ya à peu
près d'1 minute et on est en train de
compter les paniers mois il commence à
petit peu fatigué ça se voit mais puis
sont très excités donc ça soit aussi ça
pique pas trop mais ça va venir je pense
et oui les jeunes de trappes et des
clubs environnants ont tenu une heure
nombre de paniers réalisé plus de 2000
grâce à leur investissement un chèque de
800 euros a pu être reversés au téléthon
autres communes autre ambiance mais
toujours pour la même cause
à magny les hameaux l'association
objectif téléthon a sollicité la
comédienne virginie lemoine de diverses
façons je participe chaque année au
téléthon j'ai toujours fait des choses
une fashion avec mon chien fait faire
des reportages à lyon j'ai fait toutes
sortes de choux et donc de donner un
tout petit peu de son temps
simplement pour soi même bien reprendre
conscience de ça avant même de rendre
hommage
tous les bénévoles qui veut très
sérieusement et considérablement donnent
de leur temps et rendre hommage aux
malades qui sont toujours d'une dignité
absolue c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
le des temps ça permet d'avoir des
nouveaux médicaments
et bien que la science avance le
paiement christophe mauduit est atteint
de sclérose en plaques sa mère
s'investit depuis de nombreuses années
dans l'association manier coise pour le
téléthon qui compte actuellement 25
bénévoles commencent à travailler en
avril on a des collecteurs on a des
personnes qui s'occupent plus de
l'administratif
on a des gens qui s'occupent de la
décoration
la tuque
genève chacun a un rôle bien au chaud
avec objectif téléthon d'autres
associations participent à l'événement
au programme spectacles de danses
démonstrations de sports et activités en
tous genres vont en effet toutes les
animations
qu'est ce que tu as préféré tient à
l'arc et toi qu'est ce que tu as préféré
à gagner quelque chose à gagner quoi
genre sauf qu'il ya moins de monde que
l'année dernière we7 la crise on espère
faire mieux que l'année dernière mais
voilà on sait pas ça fait combien
d'année dernière quand une petite on a
fait un peu plus de 300 euros
aujourd'hui les bénévoles de manille
peuvent être fiers ils ont récolté 20
1452 euros presque autant qu'en 2011
mais il s'agit pour l'instant d'un
chiffre provisoire
tous espèrent atteindre et même dépasser
la somme de l'an dernier